despite critics favorable reception of
usa network's dark team drama demi
it wasn't until the show's 10 episodes
debuted on netflix that it truly
garnered attention
now the cheerleading thriller based on
megan abbott's novel of the same name
is keeping everyone on the edge of their
seats as it recently hit the number 7
spot in the most watched tv
series on netflix in the us gritty teen
dramas are always in season
and demi captivates audiences in an
effective way by pulling viewers into
the lives of cheerleaders and
best friends beth cassidy played by
marlo kelly and addie hanlon
played by horizon f guardiola the story
is sent into motion when the new
cheerleading coach colette french played
by willa fitzgerald
arrives and takes away best power over
the squad with its promise of blood and
its depiction of the darker side of
cheerleading
dare me more than delivers on the
thriller aspect steve green from
indiewire wrote that whenever a member
of the cheerleading squad goes quote
flying through the air a safe landing is
never guaranteed he added watching these
aerial maneuvers against a sea of
psychological chaos is a contrast that
not only gives this usa series its
anxiety but also its artistry
demi's success lies in the performances
of its leads and its carefully built
atmosphere
usa network critics generally agreed
that the series three leads who hadn't
been in many notable roles before demi
performed wonderfully
i'm the captain we're not doing captains
anymore no i'm captain this is my squad
it's mine the hollywood reporter's
daniel feinberg wrote
kelly in particular has a magnetic pull
to her and an effortless ability to
transition from innocent to animalistic
demi features a tantalizing blend of
guilty pleasure trashiness
smart genre deconstruction and
unfiltered darkly comic adrenaline
feinberg also compared the show to both
netflix's u and hbo's euphoria but
argued dare me was better
still if there's one misstep these
cheerleaders make it's dragging the
story on for a few episodes too long
alan steppenwall of rolling stone wrote
in his review of the show
abbott and her tv collaborators are much
more interested in atmosphere than plot
the latter takes a very long time to
materialize
though the former becomes so
intoxicating that the long wait begins
to feel besides the point
in the end demi isn't here to make
anyone comfortable but instead to
explore something
dark buried within its teenage leads in
the wake of the show's meteoric rise to
the top 10 most popular series on
netflix
viewers who have been fans of the series
since it first premiered on usa network
in december 2019
are experiencing a wave of hope
specifically fans are hoping that the
show's success on the streaming platform
will be enough for either usa network
itself to reverse course and renew this
series for a second season
or for netflix to pick it up and hand
down a season 2 order one fan tweeted
can netflix take dare me and make a
season 2 please
another fan tweeted directly to netflix
tagging the company's account and then
stating
hey demi is in your top 10 shows and
trending you think you want to pick it
up for a season 2 please
even audiences who are just now getting
into dare me thanks to its arrival on
netflix are clamoring for more
fans new and old have joined forces to
create and sign a petition urging
netflix to renew the show for a second
season
this is an addition to the many saved me
petitions created at the time the series
cancellation was announced in april
2020.
while it remains to be seen whether the
request will have any significance in
the eyes of netflix executives
it can't hurt to try you
are so close to having
everything that you want
fingers crossed and pom poms up that
good news will be around the corner for
demi if nothing else though at least the
series will be remembered as one that
captivated audiences
as soon as it aired its first episode
and continued creating buzz
over a year later check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one